stop the show Gang let's talk about that
middle class famous store baby oh baby
coming up to the fourth quarter on that
down to the Finish Line only a few times
to see us again gang It's a Good Time
come on out and see the live show to mix
a stand-up comedy plus we played a
little late YG with the crowd it's a
great way to introduce new people to the
show so bring the squad with ya yeah
gang this week we're going to be we have
one show left on sale in Atlanta on uh
November 12th and we're going over there
to Charlotte North Carolina uh
Philadelphia sold out you snooze you
lose we got some tickets left for the
second show in Providence Rhode Island
in December and we got some a few
tickies left for our second show in
Boston in December get those hickies
let's party gang this episode is brought
to you by our good pals and established
titles good Lord with established thumbs
you could buy as little as one square
foot of dedicated land and you yourself
can be a lord or a lady it's a fun way
to preserve the Scottish Woodlands over
there with every order established
titles plants a tree and works with
global Charities to support Global
reforestation efforts yeah think about
that huh I'm a lady my friend's title
packs give you at least one square foot
of dedicated land on private estate in
edelston Scotland plus you get an
official certificate with a Crest right
here Read It and Weep bozos I am a land
owner Daddio yeah try to kick me out of
a restaurant uh guys we're coming in to
uh the holiday season it makes an
amazing last minute gift easy peas It's
a good time all I have to think about it
established titles is running a Black
Friday sale right now plus if you use
the code garbage there you go an
additional 10 off the top gotta use the
code what a boy he's [ __ ] saying you
go to established titles.com to get your
gifts now and help support this channel
one more time get the pen out
establishtitles.com garbage to get your
gifts now help support the channel get
additional 10 promo code garbage do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit there with your favorite
comedians and we find out they're going
to be classy yeah or to just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at antuti's basement she
stole the easy pass out of my car I know
yeah she could have [ __ ] used the
keys she smashed the goddamn window dumb
broad Mike co-host is coming at you from
right next to me unamused this week you
win some you lose some gang what are you
gonna do he's the CEO of are you garbage
he is an international businessman and I
tell you what he's my best pal in the
whole wide world and I love him give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan hey I got you
there what's up gang thanks for tuning
in as always please make sure you rate
if you subscribe over there on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are officially
through the roof just broke a hundred
thousand subscribers today
I [ __ ] love you and then I'd be
remiss if I didn't answer didn't mention
the greatest goddamn website of all time
www.patreon.com
are you garbage check the [ __ ] out we
got [ __ ] bonus episodes ayg we got
episodes of hard feelings we got [ __ ]
a bunch of behind the behind the scenes
content check it the [ __ ] out gang we're
vlogging we're vlogging taking [ __ ]
new guy Luke out on the road we got we
got stuff of uh US Open up for Whitney
US Open up for bird on a tour bus the
whole nine yards check out a good time
gang check it out we love you how about
a nice quick shout out to our producer X
Jordan Air the magic man makes us all
look good works the ones and twos
crosses the t's dots the eyes plus she's
got a big old sausage give it up the
T-bone Toby McMullen everybody what's up
dudes hey T-Bone man we're about to have
a good time we got a real silly goose
there we go a real goof if you will
can't say that what if he's gonna cut
you open that's why I need the goddess
Canucks
you don't say goof in Canada I don't got
enough Wars going on here Jesus Christ
Toby dude I got enough beef you either
learn that the easy way or the hard way
now one of us is gonna get moosed what's
wrong with you
gang we couldn't be more excited to have
our incredibly and I mean incredibly
special guest here with us today for the
first time which is crazy uh-huh he is a
very funny stand-up comedian and
podcaster he has not one but two live
calling shows Tuesdays at nine he could
check out low value mail and Wednesdays
at 10 the bath house plus he has an
amazing special over there all on his
YouTube page and of course he is the one
half of the boys cast give it up for
Danny polish Chuck everybody
oh Manny boy
thank you very much we have Heavy
Hitters coming here and they're shocked
they're like what the [ __ ] they're you
know he really is great at them you
remember that at Contract time be
[ __ ] putting the screws to you
I got Vince McMahon on the phone the
Spells
c-o-m-k-o-m
Danny thank you so much for coming with
us as the long hair said you are a
Canadian gentleman yes and he called me
a goof which is bad how you got stabbed
in Sudbury right there
yeah was that a bed and breakfast
here the eggs benedict is phenomenal
it's not give us the skin give us a
scoop give us the backstory give us the
origin story the origin story uh I was
um from outside of Toronto okay Toronto
Tarana Canada we say that's weird
because we say Toronto but every here
everyone says Toronto yeah there's no RT
in it right for some reason we just
stopped pronouncing it all right um I
respect that and then uh what you guys
want from like the very Beginnings yeah
hit us like the babies
when you say outside what are we talking
about the verbs The Burbs yeah
Burlington Ontario okay which is about
45 minutes away
and then uh I went to school I went to
Jewish school for nine years yes
are you Jewish or was just a good point
my parents just wanted me to get hooked
up you know the basketball team was
really good he's gonna water this year
at a young age you want to actually you
say the basketball team was good so it
was like obviously not strong On
Athletics the Jewish school but this one
time we played this uh we had a bat when
I was like in the fifth grade we played
this team from uh Toronto they were like
a Yeshiva they were like the super
Jewish kids sure and they came in to
play like an exhibition basketball game
but they had to wear their keepas the
whole time so they were all literally
like dribbling with one hand and holding
it with the other no bobby pins or
anything it's just when you're running
too fast if you're on a fast break you
can't be worried about [ __ ] bobby
pins ain't gonna hold it in when you're
[ __ ] breaking like literally like one
arm or whatever and then they would it
would fall off and they'd blow the
whistle or whatever over because in
Jewish basketball I guess that is like
that's that's a stoppage that's a
commercial break
and there's a TV timeout right there we
smoke them we had six players burning in
hell
um all right so you're Jewish yeah uh
Orthodox fake Jewish by the way but yeah
like culturally Jewish culturally Jewish
yeah did you celebrate all the holidays
growing up or just like the Hanukkah we
not all all of them like not like the
out there ones like the Sukkot and all
those weird ones did the big ones the
big ones yeah Passover yeah rosh
hashanika did you do uh uh uh seder on
Friday nights uh no no Shabbat no okay
seders for Passover which I did do okay
wow
where are your folks from Russia they're
from Russia yeah okay yeah oh folks
that's all the things this guy this guy
hey but they were kicked out kind of for
being Jews all right now we're back on
they weren't really kicked out but this
guy's all over the place talking about
making headlines Danny tell us where the
submarines are Danny they're really easy
on you and your family where's the
football playing Hardball with the son
of a [ __ ]
um no but they allowed them to look
because they weren't allowed to leave
and then the moment they were left to
leave they're just like yeah I got out
and they went straight to Ontario uh
they went to Winnipeg
which you can definitely don't call
people Goofs and Winnipeg hold on I like
this story so they were they were
Russian Jews
um during during uh the Iron Curtain
yeah right yeah did they get out before
or after they got out in 75. damn so
basically because it was like you
weren't allowed to leave sure like
that's the kind of the Hallmark of these
communist countries right and then uh
yeah they keep everything in-house
they're big old walls over there we're
all having a good time over here why
would you want to leave
um but anyways and then they were like I
can't remember what they did but they
opened up the the borders for some I
think it was I don't know if it was only
Jews or like because they didn't like
Jews there very much uh and then but
they opened it up and my parents just
like got the [ __ ] out what did your mom
and dad do what would your dad do in
Russia uh they were so I wonder how old
they were they were young they were
young at that point they would have been
in their 20s my dad's uh he's retired
he's an engineer okay for the Canadian
government and did they leave their
whole family over there oh yeah dude it
was like so my grandfather
he was like a a war hero he was like in
the I don't know like he was in like the
uh was it siege of Stalingrad or
whatever holy 100 days he was in the Red
Army Yeah Yeah a hundred days where they
were basically like they were trying to
starve them out like yeah me and like
Ryan and stuff joke about it but like
literally like they were boiling their
belts like to eat them because like
that's like oh you know it's like an
animal product so no for sure yeah it
was [ __ ] up but anyways he was like a
hard got a belt that's good
give me give me a part of your shoe will
you okay save the buckle for me will you
that's not funny
no it is it has a hell of a fight I'll
tell you that no I mean there's a cool
story but anyways he was like he loved
being a communist like he was very
really well he was like you know he he
probably was born in like 1900 or
something he was just like all he knew
and he was into communism and he kicked
the [ __ ] out of the Germans they were
[ __ ] trying to starve him out over
there yeah but so but he was like in the
Communist party or whatever and then my
mom left and they kicked him out because
your mom left because they go like oh
you weren't able to raise a good
communist yeah yeah you can't even keep
your house in order exactly no legit so
it's like my mom kind of [ __ ] my
grandfather over did you ever meet them
did you ever meet yeah they moved my
grandmother's still alive actually she's
97 years old she lives in Toronto but
they move really they both moved to
Canada in like 91 or something oh [ __ ]
he did not want to go he was not happy
about it
wow because he's like doesn't never
learned English didn't end up learning
English so he why would he I mean he was
on the [ __ ] he was with the boys he
was on the winning team what the [ __ ]
you talking about got all the belt he
wants
loading this guy up with belt come over
here no one's eating Bell
the first word he learns how do you say
belt he's a he's at an Applebee's in
Toronto where's his belt yeah belt egg
and cheese let's go
but did he start to like it when he got
over here and saw what was cooking uh
not really hit a Mickey D's something no
he wasn't in any of that [ __ ] no uh he
was it was fine I mean you get to see
your family sure to live in Russia so
there's that but I think he liked Russia
to be honest it's all he ever knew sure
hey your parents parents got out in 75
yeah literally with like a suitcase no
so so my dad is like because we're just
talking about the World Cup right but
that's like an insane soccer fan like
you know he wakes up like Sunday
mornings to watch like Italian series B
sure like he all that [ __ ] right so when
the World Cup was in Russia like what
was it the last one yeah so it's really
hard to go to Russia like if you want to
go as a tourist like the visa
application is like super lengthy like
they're really like making sure who's
coming in and out I'm good yeah yeah so
I want to go because I'm like it would
be a cool thing to see sure right and so
they lifted the Visa restriction for the
World Cup where they said if you have a
ticket for a game you don't need to get
a Visa that is your visa and you that's
ridiculous crazy process so I told him
that I'm like we should go because like
we don't have to do this one that's like
no he's just never going back really
like out of principle they hate it so
much they're like we're not sure yeah
like when my when Russia lost Russia was
in the finals right I forget I think
they were I think they made it to the
finals or semifinals and then my
grandmother was like laying down and we
were watching the game and then it ended
and I walked over and I was she's like
who won and I go Rush a lot she was good
like they hate that's old that's old
country that's what I'm doing she's
spitting on the floor and stuff there's
no love lost from them no yeah that
makes sense yikes huh ah do you speak
any Russian no but I can understand it a
little bit that's pretty sweet yeah and
how's uh does your mom cook uh
traditional Russian dishes not real the
oh closest one is my dad makes her belt
[Laughter]
what would you say your mom's best
dishes well you're going home you're
like my I haven't seen you see this is
more than this is more the Jew in me but
it'll be matzo ball soup
you have a favorite one in New York
uh you know what I don't even know if
I've had a matzo ball soup Jacob's I
believe it's called Jacob's pictures
Jacob's pickles sorry Barney green grass
is nothing actually no I had uh Sables I
had one that said yeah it was fantastic
tables has one of the best smoked white
fish I've ever had yeah it's good stuff
Sam was like Russian daughters is really
good too
chocolate know somebody yeah it's good
stuff you ever have you ever have matzo
ball soup T-Bone intern Charlotte not in
Charlotte
there's a couple of meatballs we call it
chunky
yeah in Chicago though for sure yeah
yeah shout out to it God damn that's
good a little wet Bread soup yeah
this is just like a ball you ever do
that with white with Wonder Bread you
know you ball it up ball it up that's
essentially what a monster is yeah it's
a dumpling it's a dumpling yeah
delicious
um all right so your dad's an engineer
you're over there in Toronto yeah uh
what's your mom do for nine years right
Jewish girlfriend nine years then I went
just like there at the Jewish school uh
you brought your own lunch it was but
I'm I actually because the principal was
a rabbi and then I like I remember
because it was like it was connected to
a synagogue that's why I went because my
parents wanted me to go to Jewish school
it was like the only one around it
wasn't even in the city I lived in like
I went to like a different city for it
and then um but I remember one time this
kid brought a sandwich to school and
then he put it was like meat but there
was cheese on it and he got busted and
it was a whole thing really because
there's like like nobody was eating not
nobody but it like it was supposed to be
kosher like yeah like can't be floating
yeah yeah you gotta like eat in the like
the bathroom stall yeah yeah yeah huh
but for the it was just probably I don't
know okay oh [ __ ] bring your own yeah we
had like you know a sandwich day once a
month or something now with your parents
being Russian immigrants what was like
the snack situation and stuff like that
no it was uh did you have brothers and
sisters I have one brother did you
really take one of the American culture
for that were you like um yeah well the
thing is I had we had to like explain it
to my parents right right like they were
like here's a bag of grapes
it was one of those things where you
just have to be like hey you know what
our favorite thing was we would go oh
I'm sorry when so when you were a little
kid it was it was it was everything was
obviously influenced by them so it
wasn't until you got old and was aware
[ __ ] there's no Cheez-Its there's no
Doritos that's when you had to explain
the saddest thing there is no Cheez-Its
in Canada I didn't really know what
Cheez-Its were cancel the shows in
Toronto boys we ain't going go back
there they might have them now but dude
I didn't even know what Cheez-Its were
until like three years ago but I'm just
saying it wasn't me in Russia
they probably have Jesus there but it
wasn't until you were like a little bit
well I was like when I was a kid because
I go to my friend's house yeah and they
would have like I had did you ever the
one I had the one friend who's like his
[ __ ] house was like a Costco oh dude
yeah I had two of them yeah yeah look
where you're like they just had
everything they had like boxes of the
boxes
they had a pantry they had a walk-in
Pantry which I'd never seen in my life
and it was stacked to the hills yeah oh
just like crazy most processed foods
yes all right oh my God so you didn't
have any of that no as a little little
kid no and then it wasn't until you
started going other people's eyes you
had to break it into that yeah I go here
we got that we got to get this stuff I
mean it was one of the we would go
shopping I'm sure like it's not like
they would shop at Russian grocery
stores sure still whatever is available
but I remember which Community grocery
stores I would assume right no no no
there's no Jews where I grew up really
oh yeah not even a community we're on
your own not there was I the city I grew
up in is 150 000 people 10 Jews yikes
yeah those are good numbers
is that on the uh brochure
ah man that's a double whammy to a
Jewish woman by the way I want to go on
the record for saying that's a double
you don't even have the squad around it
you know you don't got you know the
Jewish community no nothing no that's
why the went to this school and that was
so far away yeah yeah because it was it
was the only one any pets growing up no
allergic which is weird because I right
now with my girlfriend she has a dog and
it's like one of the first animals I've
like not been allergic to nice pretty
good is it a golden doodle It's a yorkie
poo huh yeah but it's one of those hypo
I was even allergic to the
hypoallergenic Jesus Christ yeah like it
was a real real Jewish childhood
I wonder why you went to the school
these goddamn kid's allergic to Benadryl
we can't can't do nothing for him all
right so you go you go to you you go to
the Jewish school until what grade until
uh as we say in Canada grade eight but
you guys say eighth grade eighth grade
eighth grade I did kind of the same
thing we went I went Catholic Jewish
school
should have saw me on the court
um no I went to Catholic school until
about fourth grade yeah yeah I think
that's good though you know what I mean
you hit the roots a little bit turned
out great it was fine you know what I
will say though like it was it was fine
but like so much time I felt was in
hindsight was wasted learning all this
just dumb [ __ ] people were learning
about the Jewish religion all that stuff
I'm just like I could have been learning
anything else computer programming I
don't know any podcast any podcast live
streams I'm catching the vibe you've
stepped away from the faith a lot
am I picking up on that right I was
never in there too deep dude I was the
kid like me and my friends were always
listening to stand-up comedy like when
we were in you know sixth grade so it's
all Jews though what are you talking
about I know you took Department
is flowing yeah that's true but um
no we were like so the teacher would be
talking all this nonsense and we would
just be like cracking jokes to the point
to kick us out sure of course this is
all made up yeah like we were like 10
we're like this is nonsense I I dude I
remember being eight in CCD and there
was these two young it was like a couple
they were CCD was like our after school
uh Catholic you know Pro learning
program or whatever and it was this
young couple they were in like their 20s
and they got together just to teach CCD
and I remember being like you two really
believe I'm like you have all of you you
can go out boozing you could be an
Applebee's drinking a [ __ ] Margarita
right now and this is what you truly say
I'm like I don't buy it yeah I just
can't buy and I'll be praying for all
your souls tonight yeah I'll tell you
that heathens a bunch of animals but
yeah so it was I was very early on being
like this is not don't buy it don't buy
it so eighth grade you split you go to
public school went to public school
which was like honestly I remember my
first day being like it I I felt like Oz
it was awesome going no not the wizard
the prison show
smoking cigs he's trying to find a bobby
pin for his helper
because I'm [ __ ] Dory
sweet little
little who's awesome I don't know
Toronto dude no because like dick there
was an olive my entire childhood my
whole yeah
there's never one fight at my school
Jews do not fight each other right like
a bunch of soft handed take it to the
Lost pink-handed Jews and [ __ ] like
who were like 12 years old not fighting
okay at 12 class actions
they've never been punched I haven't
been sued multiple times I've locked up
in litigation right now but no time for
fighting
hey Danny you've been served rips off a
mustache walks away can't be let's talk
bespoke posts you mean box of also yeah
I mean box office
it's crispy outside it's cool a lot of
cool guy stuff to do in the fall now I'm
a fatty you are but you know what makes
me a cool guy what bespoke poke bust all
box awesome okay stroking post.net
everybody but the big man's trying to
put the words trying to get around his
time Toby get my pocket knife I'm gonna
cut this guy up cut your tongue out
maybe have a better chance to talk
that's bespoke pose guys we've done it a
million times to get started go to box
of awesome.com your answer gonna help
them pick the right box for you it's
cool guy [ __ ] you don't know you need to
outdoor stuff cocktail stuff it's sweet
man grooming stuff then you go cool I'm
a [ __ ] cool guy all of a sudden the
lady at the house is like your your
piece your side piece looking at you
like you're a cool guy also there you go
each box is valued at around 70 but you
only pay a fraction of that price plus
box of awesome you're supporting small
business 90 everything comes from your
box of Awesomeness from a small up and
coming brand we've been telling you for
years yeah here's the turkey baby gobble
gobble get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
enter the code garbage and check out
that's box of awesome.com code garbage
for 20 off your first box box of
awesome.com go garbage do it care about
that mint mobile love that mint mobile
baby let's talk about mint mobile gang
15 bucks a month for your cell phone
service Plus I got the family friends to
start with just two people yep and
here's the plot twist what the hunter
eight one really nope no hidden fees no
nothing that was a red herring you threw
at me 15 bucks a month I have done some
Shakespeare uh guys there's no luring
you in with free uh free subscriptions
and streaming services the blah blah
blah you cancel this you get charged
full price not at that I like that shade
though what yeah they're throwing heat
and I don't mind it there man mobile my
kind of company all plans come with a
limited talk and text high-speed data
delivered to the nation's largest 5G
Network
um switch to Mid mobile get premium
Wireless started just 15 bucks a month
like we've said here it is the turkey
gobble gobble get premium Wireless for
15 bucks a month and no one expected
plot twistmit mobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage seriously make
your wallet very happy at mintmobile.com
garbage today do it Ryan Reynolds back
to the show yeah but yeah and I remember
the first day of high school was like 10
fights I go what is going on really yeah
it was good though did you ever get you
ever get any scraps in high school
because you're uh you know really no I'm
not a fighter
fighter I know but typically most
comedians will back themselves into
trouble making fun of somebody
I was no I was ever specifically I like
I did love to go watch the fights though
because you know that whole thing where
they go like hey 3 P.M like yeah over
baseball diamond and I would be there
with oh man taking bets take your bets I
love that you used to love that yeah
everybody's adrenaline would just be the
hormones in the adrenaline
your the hairs would be standing up on
your arms yeah I remember there's this
one kid too he would always get in
fights this kid I remember his name was
Jeremy and but he would always lose like
but he was always getting into fights
but like he was like you're never
winning it's like the attention I guess
like he would just be walking around I
remember seeing him walking around the
hallway one's face just like bloody like
it was just like nothing because he's
like yeah again another one in the last
time he probably had a rough home life
well I don't know how many kids were in
your high school do you remember like I
want to say like 1500 okay yeah so I
went for this like tiny school to this
like big ass High School right so
there's about three 400 in your grade
something like that well so and when I
went to school high school in Ontario
was five years okay yeah that's right
yeah and then they got rid of it like I
think a year devastated if I graduated
they're like no only four now after well
there was a yeah there was a year where
the four years and the five years
graduated at the same time ah right and
then so gone
as though that would have been good what
do you mean because I would have loved
to have an extra year after my senior
year would you Gloria yeah except for
that sports high school sports in Canada
is like not good no good no even college
sports is not good really I mean if
you're playing college sports in Canada
that means you couldn't even get in like
a junior college in the U.S huh like for
sports like it's a little like even
Canadian uh college hockey is not good
which you think it would be sure but
they're all going everywhere else and
they snatch up all the all the real
talent that like 19 kids
14 they go to like the OHL but like even
the call like you know like Minnesota
and like all those like those college
teams like they're all all the good
Canadian players that are either going
to the OHL or they're going uh going to
the U.S U.S yeah gotcha all right fair
enough so yeah the high school suck too
uh for sports just in general it was
fine yeah yeah I just smoked a lot of
weed it was pretty cool oh the lunch is
like there
lunches oh the cafeteria was good
actually I it was like disgusting but
good nice not a vegetable like you could
not purchase a vegetable which I
remember like thinking later on being
like that's crazy you couldn't get a
vegetable the best was the crappy
poutine yes poutine at school oh man
that's the most Canadian [ __ ] I've ever
heard in my life man everybody
dude just hand out NyQuil they shot it
at you with a hockey stick
have you guys been to Canada I've been
to Canada yes uh I don't know if I've
had proper poutine in Canada though we
had cheese curds recently okay that's a
third of it and
Indianapolis I will say protein is
actually the most American food what is
it it's gravy cheese curds and french
fries that is Disco Fries yeah that's on
paper should be like the like a most
American thing yeah I've had it it's I
mean yeah it's good our version just has
mozzarella cheese
yeah throw it in my cafeteria but that's
because you're not getting cheese curds
in a goddamn High School cafeteria
gotcha gotta draw the line somewhere I
mean it's not a Michelin star restaurant
what was the name of the grocery store
that your mom went to Growing Up Danny
Price Chopper All Right Price Chopper
which I don't even think exists anymore
that sounds like a motorcycle game
Price Choppers yeah the savings run and
that sounds like a bad rapper from the
early 2000s and then there was also
another one which was called I think I
think it was ah [ __ ] I can't remember
there was one where like a mobs like a
mob family owned a really I can't
remember if it was like spook it at
least it was something like that it was
like four there's a thing called
Fortinos but there was a different one
and there was like some crazy mob family
like going to I like that okay I think
there's a price I don't know if that the
business is cross over because Price
Chopper I remember hearing about that
when I was a kid there was a couple
Price Choppers floating around in the
U.S we in Canada steal ideas
like that okay like they'll just like
they'll straight up now no they'll be
like oh there's a thing that's happening
in America but like they'll never come
to Canada sure so then they'll just I
think like trademark and everything it's
only four countries right I think so
yeah kid's not much of a patron I'll
tell you that it's a real flip-flop I
mean the Russians the Canadians I
gotta say Canadian Mafia got to be the
least threatening crime family I don't
think so no oh sorry about breaking your
knees there oh no that's two bottles of
maple syrup next week okay I think
they're tough customers no they're the
ones in the Montreal they're all hooked
up with like the actual like a lot of
money up there there's a lot of
bootlegging back in the day that's how
they all got their start they would get
uh they would get all the booze from up
here yeah Canadian whiskey Canadian
whiskey you guys like the Browns
not a whole bunch without dabbling
anything what the booze yeah the brown
ones yeah I'll go into it like a little
whiskey every once in a while yeah
um more of a spiced rum man
what am I 13 what are we doing here
um so your parents did good your dad was
an engineer yeah your parents are doing
all right yeah they're doing residents
or like a apartment condo we lived in um
like a
a townhouse like a connected one at
first and then we moved like literally
to a detached one up the street
like when I was like three fair enough
your parents love Canada right they were
happy today oh my parents loved him okay
yeah they I mean like anywhere if they
were on like you know prices right and
they won and all include like trip to
Russia they wouldn't take it yeah nice
I know for sure like they're like we
would not that's the only way they can
come across an all-inclusive vacation
also what's all-inclusive looking like
in Russia a lot of boys swim up bars
I've heard it I've heard like Moscow and
stuff's like I'm sure there's so much
money I mean they're you know there's a
lot of people certain people have so
much money from what I hate the bad ones
what was the pizza situation growing up
pizza situation so Ontario has the worst
chain of uh Boston no Boston Pizza sucks
so bad too that only exists in Canada
dude Boston is even known for pizza no
and when Boston Pizza open up we all
assumed it was Mississippi
legitimately everybody was like oh where
this must be a chain of of American and
then you find out you're like wait only
we have this place I found that out I
was real confused Boston Pizza sucks no
there's a thing called Pizza Pizza which
is like the biggest change
of pizza pizza pizza
and it's the worst like dude if you go
eat a slice of pizza there after coming
from here you'll be like what is
happening I like bad Pizza though I want
it on the record I love bad Pizza love a
slice of bad Pizza 7-Eleven
yeah oh yeah I mean if I have to I had
it in Philly four nights ago
really yeah when we were in Florida we
got good I don't I I'm there's no bad
Pizza to me no I agree with you on that
and actually at 3am if you're kind of
drunk and you want to do a 7-Eleven and
grab like a full pie for like eight
dollars or something pretty good so yeah
and it's done in a minute yeah it's
right there it's ready to go what are we
doing
um what about the Chinese spots up there
oh and it was good they're what nah I
mean would you guys do that would you
guys do the traditional Jewish move on
Christmas Chinese in a movie no we never
my parents didn't love Chinese food we
do it occasionally but I had lots of
friends who did that but we never did
that we were just chilling really yeah
never did the Chinese food huh were you
guys a shoes off household yes real very
strict
uh yeah yeah that was so that's a funny
Canadian American thing it's like we
always used to watch American sitcoms
and American sitcoms everybody just like
has their shoes on in their [ __ ] bed
oh yeah
you're like what are you doing yeah yeah
I just noticed that the other day on
something too yeah it was like Fresh
Prince he'd like have his shoes on in
his bed he has like a winter coat on or
whatever
they like your shoes you're like take
your shoes off you got shoes people uh
shoes off in the house for the most part
if company came over they would leave
their shoes yeah like I like a bunch of
people because you know like there's
just yeah if I got if I could if me and
my friends came home after school it's
like shoes off yeah but if you were an
adult you know my mom wasn't making you
take your shoes off for sure sure we
left them on on like dirt bags
um what was the bar mitzvah situation
the bar mitzvah situation uh I had was
it a Throwdown was it nice it was I saw
me and my best friend uh Adam we uh
because usually like a lot of kids would
have their own party but our friend our
family was like pretty close we were
good friends so we shared it we had like
a [ __ ] I like that
what was the take
was that oh I don't know dude I didn't
touch a dime of that money really it
just went to my for my school
holy [ __ ] yeah yeah dude I had one
friend but that's also like Russian
immigrant parents were like yeah we're
not giving this guy 10 grand what do you
know the whole point what are we doing
here yeah yeah well that's depends where
you're all my boys are all caked up dude
my I had one friend who's was like
probably the richest friend I had period
and his grandfather gave him ten one
thousand dollar bills whoa just his
grandfather like that's 40 million
dollars
10 wait what is that ten one thousand
dollar bills ten Grand but this is a 96
a million dollars yeah it's like a 96
even though they made thousand dollars
in yeah
they're not in circulation but they
exist you got to give them a Price
Chopper can I cash this yeah they're
like they all get taken out of
circulation or whatever and like if you
ever drop one off at the bank
it's like a two dollar bill yeah yeah
all right so nothing big nothing crazy
on the bar mitzvah didn't touch it I
didn't touch it I I wasn't feeling yeah
I didn't get it I have a familiar story
about my Holy Communion yeah Patty yeah
my mom kept all my money what was the
vacation like vacation
um we went on a few decent ones we went
what was the the biggest one I'd say is
so my my dad used to fly a lot for work
okay so he used to like rack up the air
miles I was always jealous of those kids
they'd be like going to Hawaii on Miles
yeah yeah yeah so he used to because
like I guess he just got the air miles
but so when my his whole like when the
whole family like left Russia lots of
people they just went all over like they
didn't all go to Canada so we had all
these cousins which I had never met and
my dad hadn't seen in 35 years or
something in Australia what yeah who
like literally like I had never met any
of them and like they had it's weird
because they had the same last name but
spelled totally differently because when
you show up they go like how do you
spell it and you're like I don't know
genetically yeah well then you're like
what's your name and you tell it to them
and then some guy just goes like it
sounds like this yeah it sounds like
this takes a stab at it and so there was
like there's all different spellings
but uh so that was a cool one Australia
that's nice that's a big trip for a
[ __ ] kid man oh yeah for sure that's
big for anybody how were the cousins how
was that vacation it was uh it was funny
the funniest thing it was cool but it
was um I'd say the funniest part of it
was you guys watched Degrassi no because
that's the most Canadian question
anyone's ever asked me dude I went to
Australia this is 99 or something I go
to the first thing I never met any of
these cousins they go first question
they go do you watch Degrassi really
there's a Nickelodeon show right uh well
it's like here but it was a Canadian TV
he's a legendary Canadian TV show it was
before this is before Drake it was never
like saved by the bellish it was like a
High School drama but it dealt with all
this like really like there was like a
kid got shot and killed in school one
kid had AIDS like way or there was like
a gay kid this is like way before any of
that stuff was going on gotcha and it's
like it's like an institution in Canada
yeah okay and Drake was on it shout out
Drake where's he Drake
huh any injuries there's no Drake No oh
any oh God so many I broke my arm what
uh I was hobbed because I was just a Jew
um I uncoordinated Jew I was
hopscotching through a ladder one day
that happened to be laying down yeah and
then just tripped and just looked at my
arm and it was like real bad seed this
one broke my broke my leg my uh ankle
playing Foursquare one time
playing touch football in the rain
wearing like basketball shoes which had
zero grip don't know what I was thinking
broke my leg and then actually right
before I moved to America we had this
pickup game
um this is like three years ago three
and a half years ago
with a pickup game in this uh there's
all these like Comedians and film people
and then I uh I tore my calf muscle ah
Jesus yeah it honestly it hurts a bit
but it's the weirdest thing because like
uh you lose like you just can't it's
like almost like a hydraulic yeah yeah
use like so I'm like looking at my foot
and I'm just like I can't move it I
would have thought I was parallel
dude yeah yeah and I have to be like
taken out of the J the gym was
underground slightly it was like a half
level it was in this like sure Rec
Center or whatever so then after that
they have to like call the ambulance and
I had to like get taken out in an
ambulance I lost good Healthcare up
there dude I gotta go I got the bill for
it eight cents 45 bucks there you go
damn there you go less than my co-pays
your most athletic achievement was
playing against more Jewish kids oh yeah
yeah oh absolutely yeah that's where the
no question um have you ever saved a
Crown Royal bag
ooh ah no I have not but my father sure
definitely a big Crown guy really big
Crown guy he likes Canadian brand yeah
of course yeah no dad likes a pop oh
he's Russian yeah yeah dude a lot of
Russian kids and like Russians like same
as you like first generation and their
parents it was like we'd be like 13 and
they would just bottles of vodka yeah it
was Russian Jewel vodka yeah and it
would just come by they had cases in
case and they just ah you can have one
yeah well I remember one time I snuck
beer and they were like whoa like you
can't have beer like these are Coors
Lights dude I gotta lay off the [ __ ]
vodka for a little bit oh man my you're
drinking 90 Proof
we would drive later pal raycon baby
uh-huh have you started shopping for the
holidays yet no I haven't get on it
right now you can shop early skip the
stress some of the best deals of the
season on something everyone will love
what's that premium audio products from
Ray
oh my God everyone needs a pair of
raycons in their ears whether it's for
listening to music there you go talking
on work calls or blasting a workout
playlist some might do regularly there
you go these wireless earbuds headphones
and speakers off of premium sound
comfortable fit and up to 54 hours of
battery life you're probably saying that
how much is going to cost you it's half
the price of the premium audio Brands
batteries tight plus raycon makes it
easy to shop for every Tom Dick and Aunt
Tutti in your life a holiday gift guides
baby try shopping raycon's holiday
bundles their best buds bundle get you
30 off two pair everyday earbuds
um here it is right now go to buy
raycon.com garbage use the code early BF
to get 20 off site wide that's 20 off
any rate com product which almost never
happened so take it baby uh or save even
bigger get 30 off raycons exclusive
holiday bundles that's code early BF at
biracon.com garbage for 20 off your
raycon purchase buy recon.com
established titles baby we're back let's
be neighbors hear you here you gang we
need a bell
please rise the lordy Lady of all you
garbage yes
gang do yourself a favor now you've
heard a lord of the dance but let's talk
about screwing me on the [ __ ]
teleprompter can't be guys establish
tells you by as little as one square
foot of dedicated Landing call yourself
a lord or a lady you know it by this
point they're a good company get
involved title packs give you at least
one square foot a dedicated land on a
private estate in edelston Scotland baby
those are my line an official
certificate with a crass boom right here
big man you're out get my white glove
I'm slapping them your certificate has
it you can all treat a lady like that
your certificate has a plot number so
you can see the location of your land
and here is the goods baby the first 200
people purchased purchasing a title pack
using our link effectively be next to
our place within a few minutes of
walking we can build our garbage Kingdom
I'm finally King of the land what I
always wanted
uh guys go to established titles uh
makes an amazing last minute gift
established titles is running a Black
Friday sale plus you use the code
garbage you get an additional 10 off go
to establishals.com garbage get your
gifts now and help support the channel
do it back to the show back to the show
so sometimes for like so you know some
sort of like family gathering or some
sort of something like you'd go to like
which is my most hated thing was these
Russian restaurants
shout out to the golden gates and uh
Northeast Philadelphia oh yeah I did a
show there one time it's dude those
Russian those Russian restaurants are
wild dude we have a nice spread though
you didn't like it I never they have
just some weird foods I didn't like I
don't like you know you eat chicken or
whatever potatoes but like have you ever
seen the there's I can't remember what
it's called it's called like far or
something it's it's like a soup it looks
like soup but it's uh it's like chicken
Jello oh I know what you're talking you
know what I'm talking about if I don't
want to it looks like a bowl of chicken
soup but you can like do the Dairy Queen
thing where you can yeah oh it's a
little thick no it's a lot thick it's
like it's a full Jello it's like it's a
gelatin mold it's a gelatin mold yeah
with like they're called something
Chicken in it oh I do know what the oh
yeah people tag Us in that [ __ ] I've
seen that yeah really yeah I want to say
it starts with a P was that they were
actually like they got popular in
America in the 50s oh for some reason oh
but uh the Russian restaurants are wild
you walk into one on like 2 p.m on a
Sunday afternoon which is when we go and
it's like a nightclub yeah they really
do they have like ballet and stuff no
but like everybody's like all in
blue ball you're like
and you walk in and you're in Moscow
but those things would be like all my
you know family and stuff and like they
would polish off so much vodka they
party like there's just every table you
sit down and there's a bottle carafe
yeah vodka I like it all right
um how do you feel about quiche
quiche I am ambivalent I don't hate a
quiche I don't like it the only time
ambivalent has ever been said on the
spot yeah it's the classiest answer thus
far it really is I'll never order a
quiche sure but I'll never turn down a
quiche I completely agree it just
doesn't do anything
um have you ever got have you ever worn
shoes on the beach
yes
that is not a good look are you a beach
guy ah yes I have I used to not be a
beach guy and then I became more of a
beach are you a Tau guy on the beach or
a chair guy on the beach you bring the
chair out depends if like I'm fine with
a towel but if I happen to be having a
chair I'll I'll bring a chair I feel
certain body types
you gotta be a In-Shape guy to be a
towel guy yeah really otherwise it looks
like he looks like he got shot if you're
laying there it's not like a it's not
like you're catching Rays it's like
you're trying to survive type thing I go
barber's chair
do you have to have a swimsuit on or
will you swim in something else pair of
shorts you own a swimsuit I own
one swimsuit okay and it's actually like
a basketball show that's pretty shabby
to be honest has a lot of holes in it
okay
piranhas
saw Waters just eating it away uh no I
would go in the ocean in like uh shorts
okay
you pee in the ocean oh yeah poop in the
ocean I've never [ __ ] in water I
honestly yes okay
okay yes be in the shower for sure I've
never uh [ __ ] I've done an aqua dump
Aqua dump that's pretty good that's
pretty good bumps all right uh if you go
out to a restaurant will you when you
when you're done eating will you stack
the plates a little bit oh yeah you do I
do stack the plates okay my girlfriend
hates it yeah it's yeah that's the
nicest thing ever I honestly it is out
of just like I go like yeah let's just
get this easy help them out I like it I
like it what's your personal objection
to that
hey what's your [ __ ] problem I mean
we've gone
we've gone over this a lot I think if
it's like baskets or something if you're
like at a bar and it's baskets of wings
yeah but otherwise uh you know
it just it's like it seems like it's
wildly impatient like they're gonna be
around in two seconds like a minute oh
I'm impatient for sure yeah so it's like
just let them do the job sometimes I
just won't want it in front of me like I
won't want like if I ate something I
just like I don't want this in front of
me anymore sure plate so I'll just like
move it and then stack and just like it
never happened oh yes no that's weird to
me yeah did you ever work in the service
industry uh no well I worked I sold I
worked at uh this place called Future
Shop which was basically Best Buy if
that counts but
wireless devices there even better one
actually so there were three there were
two main electronic stores there was
Future Shop and this place called 2001
audio video and it was 2008 God damn it
dude that one is still if I'm if I'm I
believe that one still exists 2001 audio
video it outlasted future shot
hand there's a place but there's is it
still Toby checking is it is it around
still oh yeah 2000 and it's like the
shittiest like it was they kind of like
took over for Radio Shack when all the
Radio Shacks left so I think whale looks
like dumb little like you know hey I
need like a coax splitter sure yeah a
cheaply made rc car everything yeah all
that stuff yeah uh 2001 audio video
we've got one down there in Kitchener
yeah put one over there in St Thomas
there you go St Thomas sounds nice tell
them jumbo jumbo jumbo Joe Thornton
that's where he's from hmm pride of St
Thomas
only the hockey fans will know
um are there any milk crates at your
parents house at the moment oh I I know
but you don't know about the bags
a bag of milk delicious it's milk yeah
I'm not we used to be a big meal family
put the bag in the refrigerator they
give you like I don't know how to do it
up there and and how do you put a bag
what do you know about bag milk look at
them what do you mean he has a bag of
milk
I resent that
I'm ambiguous to that comment
I'm amphibious to your insults
uh there is a local Farm near me called
Merry Maid Farm shout out to them my
buddy's parents used to get milk
delivered from there and it came in a
bag and you would get they had they
always had this at the house it was like
a pitcher yeah that you would just slide
it in and put the lid on yeah so you
have a plastic so this way we made fun
of it we didn't have six years so our
family didn't have they were on great
milk it was you put it's a bag it's like
so I think it was a gallon right because
we don't even have gallons so they're
like
1.3 liters no no so each bag for three
bags is a gallon okay that makes sense
so they're 1.3 liters each and they're
like yeah they're like a long bag but we
didn't have the one with the lid so
you'd put it in and then some fanless
milk some families
[ __ ] dust bunnies
because you don't cut the top like this
you cut the corner yeah but then
sometimes the weight the weight would be
kind of off and you would cut it and
just go like and then I'll dump out and
then some fans this is the most
practical thing in the world no it sucks
cartons are so much better and then uh
some families would have this like
magnet on their fridge that hat it was a
milk bag cutter magnet like Canadians
know exactly what I'm talking about and
you would like and they would never be
sharp enough and you'd have to like try
and cut the corner and just be better
for scissors but some people have the
magnet that's the milk was pretty good
though it
got it I mean if anything gets worse
than plastic no well is that in the
stores too it's a plastic bag yeah
that's in the stores too that's only in
the stores I don't know how much I think
they still have it yeah but I always
have cartons now I like my milk that was
it's just me personally in a roller bag
we got a duffel a skim
um how are they laid out in the grocery
store they're in hanging on books flat
in the old section on the bottom of the
cooler all of this is so impractical
three bags in one they probably [ __ ]
better you probably take up less space
shipping wise I would guess because it's
liquid it's liquid so it takes up the
minimal amount yeah but I mean it's I
put like square or whatever wise
you're only losing the container of the
box so the reason Canada is milking bags
they're backwards
nobody says
they stole all the containers they also
get this I got Boston pizza and pizza
pizza
pizza
it's crazy that the biggest pizza chain
is just the slogan for an American Pizza
chain all right when Pierre Trudeau LED
Canada's conversion to the metric system
in the 1970s they had to switch all the
containers
I'm packaging from gallons to pounds or
liters to kilograms uh so milk producers
opted to switch to plastic bags to avoid
the expensive task of molding new
cartons or jugs
okay yeah so I didn't even know that yes
it was a cost saving measure at that
time yeah in the 70s
I'm pretty sure
so like you genuinely can't buy a carton
of milk you can now but like when I was
a kid there was definitely you like
creamer like the little guy yeah but
like bagged milk was just that's what it
was you imagine dealing with a little
creamer like that
dude when I was in actually in Jewish
school we had uh like a chocolate milk
day and it came in these little look
like a [ __ ] breast implant like it
was like you got a bag of chocolate you
guys are [ __ ] backwards you're so
close and yet so far away and it's wild
yeah Jesus and it was like you have to I
remember it you have to like push they
had instructions on how to drink the
milk so you have to like push the one
side to make it like tight and then you
stabbed it with a it's like an upside
down Capri Sun yeah like some from the
space station somebody I don't I don't
know what comic said it was like it was
like aliens came down to America and
then went back to their home planet and
tried to convey what America looked like
and that's
like there's milk but it's in a bag and
our soda comes in our shoes
you guys don't even understand like
since I moved here like I have to change
my vocabulary and how I spell
what do you mean oh what do you throw
the U in there yeah I gotta stop and my
autocorrect still thinks I'm Canadian so
then it's telling me all the stuff I'm
spelling what do you mean like favorite
throws the U in there and there's a u
color
you
dude all the metric like I I remember at
a joke or something dude washroom so
it's like we say washroom in Canada
bathroom yeah I don't I don't say it
ever anymore like you they we say
bathroom as well but like I remember I
asked I'm not sure somebody would know
what you're talking about I asked
someone I would be like if someone asked
me if you're doing a bit and you're like
and then I went to the washroom oh sure
yeah but I remember I had a joke or
something and I said you know when
you're in a washroommate I said leader
in your bag of milk I gotta change it to
like gallon and this guy's over he drank
three liters of beer you're like what
the [ __ ]
this guy sounds crazy huh that's only
two bags
[Laughter]
everything uh is it drugstore or
Pharmacy
I think either Pharmacy probably more
than I think I grew up with drugstores
but there is drugs drugstore too though
Supermarket or grocery store
yeah have you ever used a business
center actually more actually backpack
backpack yeah it was backpack Tony just
made fun of me for saying school I think
it was you guys yeah he wasn't even I
love school book bag it was backpack I
love school bag have you ever used the
business center at a hotel yes for what
I don't remember but it was a nightmare
he wouldn't be the first guy they never
work right dude no I had to print
something yeah because I had to print
something and then they're like you know
you're on like a I don't know a computer
from 25 years ago or something trying to
figure this out the tip there is to send
to the front desk and have them printed
yeah I think that's it just [ __ ] I
think that's eventually what happened
before and get your [ __ ] together I
needed to princess oh I just need to
print it in the moment and I go like you
know it's everyone has that is showing
us I don't know nobody has a printer
ever huh you know you know anybody with
adult braces
do I know anybody uh I must
uh anyone in your family ever have them
my brother had them right as an adult no
no oh yeah no I mean but now adult
braces like they're all the Invisalign
you don't even know I know true it's the
right way to do it like you probably do
know people with adult braces and you
don't even know they have them right now
true I'm talking the yeah yeah
that doesn't exist anymore my buddy's
dad had them but like 90s in the 90s it
freaked us out yeah it was weird with
the the rubber bands a whole nine yeah
he had it all a lot he'd wear his
headgear he worked from home and he'd
wear his headgear and walk around like
how am I supposed to dick you do
go get me a sandwich
stuffy in a locker
um sorry do you shake your drinks no no
no I don't uh no even I guess well only
one specifically that must be
um
yeah if it says like because you have
all the sediment and stuff but okay uh I
don't even do the do you do the flick on
the can
no for the pro I'll tap I think really
yeah I always thought there was a trashy
thing to do
when you see you'd see something real
goof move easy does it anytime you sell
like some girl grab a soda like a
cigarette hanging out of your mouth
she'd be like King King and then open it
I'll just let it explode in my face yeah
that's what's gonna happen
um will you get a straw to drink out of
a can or will you no hey
such a [ __ ] it's crazy they hand me a
straw I I take actually [ __ ] yeah
such a New York thing that doesn't
happen in Philly you can order a can of
soda and they hand you the canister I
moved to York these [ __ ] kept
giving me straws yeah that is a New York
thing actually yeah I hate that because
they think the top of the can is so
dirty you wipe it off your shirt I
haven't done either of those things
um do you have one of those hooks that
you hang bananas on at your apartment
right now no did you grow up with one no
just uh just throwing them away a bowl
okay you have hand towels in your
apartment yes you have a full set of
towels same same thing no they're all
over they're all mismatched they're
mismatched they're like just the hand
towels
their hand towels have accumulated over
here property of when you're here
I live with my girlfriend live with your
lady right with the lady I know you're
like yes we've met yes cook bacon in the
microwave
uh I have before but I you know what
bacon kind of just like fell out of the
mix for me I don't really make it such a
mess
and I don't know my girlfriend's
vegetarian so I'm like I'm just making
it for myself at this point I only eat
bacon out uh what was the last one do
you like Canadian bacon uh only on eggs
benedict nice I am a Benny man good man
good man we call it pmail bacon all
right I'm gonna just call a female vegan
you guys call it Canadian baby Canadian
Meat yeah
meal
because it's like so the outfits you're
Canadian just call it Canadian bacon or
bacon comes wrapped in newspaper you
guys you guys Clump everything up
everything gets clunky well it's because
I guess the outer ring of it is like has
some sort of cornmeal or something maybe
pea meal I guess I I wanna that sounds
idiotic of me saying it's like but maybe
meal that's what it is
okay I mean that's almost crazy the
yellow stuff on the outside the ring
yeah I gotcha yellow it's red the casing
or whatever the casing yeah yeah it's
like some sort of
they soak it in a brine for a few days
and roll it in cornmeal which would you
would think it would be sea meal bacon
right I'll give you that that makes more
sense maybe we're not getting Real
Canadian bacon out no you are I've never
noticed cornmeal on the outside and I
would know well there you go you might
not be my corn uh I'll bring some back
next time I go do you get cash back when
you make a purchase uh
um yes I have a credit card my American
credit no no not like the cashback like
if you go to the store and you purchase
with a debit card we like give me forty
dollars
sometimes yeah but I I honestly I can't
even think of the last time that's been
asked them and I don't think they do
that much anymore the uh drugs like the
pharmacies the pharmacies are the Rite
Aids and like the you know that kind of
stuff too yeah you drive here right no
you don't drive thank God I don't drive
here you don't do you have a license oh
yeah I when I moved here I drew when I
moved from Toronto I drove down I had a
car okay uh and then like I was I had it
for two weeks I was like this is a nice
socks dude I'm like I'm like what do I
even need this for like I don't go out
of town enough like I'm not doing tons
of Road gigs where I like need a car and
wanting to do like you know whatever you
rent a car in Canada is it traditional
to flash the lights when there's a cop
ahead to the
[Laughter]
my dad was like the original ways you
know there's a mountie two clicks back
all right okay I like that
um have you ever asked to change tables
at a restaurant
I have not but I have a lot of Jewish
Family and I've been around it a lot and
I don't like it really yeah your family
sent a lot of things back at a
restaurant send a lot of stuff back no
no like it has to be like egregious good
that's good yeah like it has to be like
it's not like oh like my biggest pet
peeve if someone ordered something and
they go like I don't like this
yeah you're like you ordered it well
you're off you you chose yeah you chose
this a thing that you don't like it
wasn't made bad sure you just don't like
it I like that that's not a bad version
of a chicken parm you dude I won't even
send food back if there's a hair in it
yeah it yeah it depends on where the
meal where it is in the eating but I
might just uh I won't I like that's what
I'm not saying I'll just go around it
yeah oh I'll just I'll go pull yeah yeah
memory hold that bad boy finish my meal
I like it you ever sleep with a chair
against the door
as protection yeah no do you sleep with
anything near the bed any type of weapon
no nothing no no weapons steak Knife
scissors brass knuckles no nothing huh
no no no knives but I mean again I'm not
like I don't think I get like deported I
don't even know what you're allowed to
have
get deported hey I'm not a resident like
I'm not a
I'm not an American don't send me back I
mean like you're getting like brass
knuckles
in your apartment I don't think you can
yeah I don't know what you have brass
knuckles you're like oh groggy you hear
something you're like
I don't know it's better than not having
I'm gonna throw it out or punching
yourself in my underwear I'm just like
taking shots at people is that how you
sleep you sleep in the skivvies in that
door yeah are you doing tidy whities are
you doing boxers boxer briefs underwear
love them how many pillows are you using
I use one pillow
one pillow and then I have a second
pillow that winds up somewhere around my
body are you sleeping on your back side
sleep on your side a lot of sides
sometimes I'll put the pillow in between
my knees I like that all right that's
good one pillar in between the knees one
on well two is just too much for me I
get too much tilt in the neck what do
you do what do you do with your arms
sometimes I was around the pillow
I need one there you go all right
girlfriend's like why can't that be me
and I go I can't explain it yeah it's
crazy yeah sometimes like why can't you
face in it's I don't know so you guys
both uh live with your girls yeah one
one comforter or two
this is a this is a big debate am I will
in my life two comforters [ __ ] yeah it's
a game it's like having your own bed
instead of getting a king you get like
two doubles or whatever dude two
comforters it is the Ultimate Game
Changer it's wild so you're each wrapped
up in your own thing yeah we're like we
have we might as well be in different
rooms okay sleep in a first class it's
amazing I don't know you lady it's
pretty good man there's no tussle
there's no there's no pressure you've
never like taughtness to it exactly
you're you're in your own little world
you never wake up I highly recommend you
never wake up just like naked yeah
because you're like what the [ __ ] yeah
the exactly are you doing this too yeah
you don't tell me oh I don't know
it doesn't sound like you can handle
this info no because it does it
um we do it when we go in we did always
did it in Germany like that's how she
had her operation set up so when we go
over to her parents house that's how the
bed is as well there's two smaller uh
comforters are her parents doing the
same thing I think I think that's maybe
have you ever heard of this no this is
crazy talk no this is I'm telling you
this is such uh it's a game changer this
is like I Love Lucy with the two beds
give me two bedrooms this is kind of two
beds though because once you have your
own blankets then you're like all right
we're just there's then there's another
thing you're sharing is the surface
which like doesn't matter that much
doesn't matter it's the blanket that is
the nightmare to share it's not the bed
try it out there gang it's pretty classy
man I ain't gonna lie this guy really
hates communism
talk about the iron
if you're at a restaurant yeah uh will
you take silverware off the table next
to you if you don't have anything
absolutely yeah you will oh for sure
that's how well I will give a very like
I mean there's nobody sitting at the
table right yeah there's nobody at the
table yeah yeah yeah that's better than
asking and waiting and having them go
get it yeah just take that they can
replace it with the whole thing I'm just
trying to help them out servers hate
that I hate that I highly just ask for
it I'm telling you they hate it because
that table set up nice
if you need something ask me for it and
it might be essential that's a youth
thing now it's not a me thing it feels
like a you thing I mean you're helping
them out regardless they have to be
there you got to reset that table then
they're getting together
they were doing their job it would have
been you would have had it already oh
now I'm not doing my job
this is a you thing you ever talk to the
concierge at a hotel talk to them yeah
yeah
you want to get out of here get a bag of
milk hey what's funny have you ever used
I've legit been like right what's fun to
do around here really oh yeah
they break out the map and I want to put
a gun in my mouth man they're drawing
you a map you gotta go out here make
three buddy I got a phone just give me
the name
okay
I just picture him like post it up yeah
so what time you get done uh what's your
favorite flavor Gatorade and Pringles
favorite flavor Gatorade uh orange or
the purple uh the G2 one like the no
sugar purple one that one is actually my
favorite one it's really good there's
g2s ain't shabby it's really good that
is actually my favorite one because it
tastes like uh whatever though it's kind
of a kickback to the riptide Rush which
they stopped making we never like the
light purple
um
uh Pringles my favorite Pringles I don't
have them my favorite chip is again back
to Canada ketchup trips place okay
somebody just gave us a package of those
when we were up in the Pacific Northwest
here yeah big fan uh first concert
first concert was I think the Bare Naked
Ladies okay yeah when I was like 12.
there was no tits here yes sir it was
actually not just them it was them and
Blues Traveler all right that's a fun
concert right yeah and and that was when
they were like the most one of the most
famous bands in the world sure this is
25 years yeah
these were popular and then they blew
the roof this is when they were like and
this was in Toronto so the Blues
Travelers were a good time too and blue
shop was yeah and John at that concert
because John popper would start throwing
out his harmonicas and I got one of them
really you have a John popper harmonica
dude somewhere in my parents house
that's pretty sweet yeah who else played
on that uh Lisa Loeb Ben Harper Ben
Harper okay H yeah definitely probably
smoked weed during that and uh when I
was like 12 and then uh I can't remember
who else but those three for sure okay
and first job
first job was selling Razer scooters oh
boy in the mall
what year
were they popping this is right when
they were like getting really I was like
15 or something yeah wow would you ride
them around like that are they real so
they can do tricks no no no no no tricks
uh like you're saying did I or could I
could you no okay but I'd rip around the
mall when I was not supposed to be doing
sure like it was so I can't remember
what's the what's the uh you guys have
Spencer Gifts yeah of course so it was I
think they [ __ ] America shocked that
you do yeah yeah you guys got Wally's
wacky gifts up here
we actually have this thing called the
ID store which is a similar thing that I
went out you have I swear to God I'm not
looking for tits
uh until we cut that
um but so I think they owned like this
was I think it was Spencer Gifts but so
they had all these kiosks like they just
bought you worked at a mall Kia selling
Razor scooter and they bought this guy
stink dude they bought a million of them
or something from like China sure and so
then they opened up these kiosks like I
guess it was all over and so I was but
so there was very little supervision
right right like I had some kid who was
a manager he was probably like 20.
uh-huh and I would see him like once a
month so it was just like I was there's
not room for two and were you moving no
no before you selling yeah they were
cooking really looking but I was
knocking out this thing sold themselves
what are you talking about but because
it was like a kiosk I just like and I
was I was not a good employee I was
ripping around the mall that was you
know like taking long breaks what were
you pulling in an hour do you get a
piece of the sale no no oh
Canada probably 38 an hour ten bucks
maybe okay
um what uh it's 19 cents American what's
a food court looking like in a Canadian
I like that uh pretty normal
pretzels
[Laughter]
wacky Donald's
no pretty normal what was the name of
like the generic pizza place would be in
multiple uh there was there was uh what
was that a pizza pizza or this place
Gino's Pizza was in all the food courts
which was the worst what was the chicken
plate do you have like a chicken KFC
okay we didn't know there's also a place
churches
respectable Mary Brown's do you have a
favorite pop growing up
I like I was a big nest to you guy Nest
tea yeah like the iced tea iced tea uh
wait you call that pop as well well it
came and it came in so it was in the
same same category but it didn't it was
non-carbonated I was a Coca-Cola man
okay love an st though brisk was all
right too I never liked the brisket like
hurt my throat there was a there was a
nice bite yeah there was like something
I don't know I actually wondering what
that is
chemicals
aspartame or whatever it was yeah
I mean I'm pretty good the to me the
[ __ ] working in a mall kiosk selling
Razor scooters is kind of the nail in
the coffee for me for me did your house
have a crawl space no no uh
maybe there was one but we didn't go up
there like it was like in the roof or no
like I I like well crawl space is Downer
Canadian I guess this would be an attic
yeah but you couldn't get it like you
could get up there if you wanted to but
it was just full of it wasn't like best
access yeah gotcha yeah
I mean did your family celebrate the
legendary Canadian holiday family day ah
Family Day only started 10 years ago
uh but making up holidays
they had 10 years ago you can't the name
you could come up with was family day
do that that's it
Jesus Christ
family days so they wanted a statutory
holiday in statutory all right
because there was no they wanted so you
could have a long weekend and then they
just the government that this is what
they're cooking up in Canada this is why
I'm here by the way
doors are wacky the milk the holidays
you guys are just making up your own
rules yeah so they go hey how about
family day and I think it's not even the
same I could be wrong on this it might
not even be the same day in every
Province or something they also got
provinces up there
it's the sixth Wednesday of every month
except for every other year it's on
Thursday
yeah family day's like 10 years old I
think ladies and gentlemen
Danny
100 Drake oh I'm telling you're right
yeah you stink you're trash Canada
stinks but we love you you weren't even
stealing from the razor kiosk I would
have gave you some points tonight
but I would take really long like I
remember one time we had this little in
the do you ever work in a mall no what
so so in like the parents who loved me
in the bowels of the mall is where all
the storage is so our little kiosk room
would be like where all the storage
because you can't keep a lot out there
right yeah yeah bring them as they say
also I would go in there sometimes and
just take like hour-long naps because
you put the back in five minutes sign
out but nobody knows when you put it out
and you're not you're not wetting your
beak on these sales so who cares no be
quiet real right real Renegade let me
tell you
those goddamn razor excuses I was going
for eight minutes
Danny you got anything coming up you
want the folks to know about plug away
just just the shows uh of course yeah I
love Valley mail Tuesday nights the bath
house live from the Green Room of the
stand on Wednesdays which either of you
guys any of you guys would love to love
it yeah it's a fun time people call in
it's a mess and then uh the boys shout
out to the boys shout out we've done it
go check out that episode if you haven't
checked it out great time great time
buddy we love you I love you thank you
for coming in gang we love you we'll see
you next week peace peace